the thing we always say is half not half
ass the idea is like whatever you're
doing cut it in half you're thinking
like you're thinking too big probably to
start keep cutting things in half
otherwise it's gonna be half-assed
you're gonna do this big idea and you're
not really gonna do anything very well
you're really you really ought to focus
just on like one thing and do it really
really really well and focus on the
basics the basics are where it's at I
mean like you go to a hotel and they
fancy furniture everywhere and they get
a big-screen TV in the room whatever but
if the beds not comfortable Hotel sucks
right like if you fly in a plane and
they've got the fancy Wi-Fi in the plane
whatever but the planes always two hours
late it sucks
like you've got to get the basics right
you got to get the bed right in the
hotel you gotta get the on-time arrivals
right in the airline business you know
like the trains have to run on time that
sort of thing like if you're in the
interview business you got to do good
interviews work on that first that's
hard enough the idea that you can like
solve that problem and solve ten other
problems at the same time it's just a
bad thing so I'm always telling people
cut cut cut get to the core the real
essence of what it is that you're doing
and do a really good job at that focus
on the basics the basics are never gonna
go out of style they're not sexy but
they're never gonna go out of style like
you'll be using a post-it note in 20
years I promise you but are you gonna be
using this newfangled note-taker thing
that you know I don't know I'm probably
not but you'll be using post-it notes
because they work and they're essential
and that sort of thing so you got to
kind of get your idea down to that
simple essence so that's what I keep
telling people
well you know I'm not a big fan of
looking out that far so like why am i
excited to get up tomorrow because I
like the stuff we're working on tomorrow
not I like the stuff we'll be working on
in six months but really to me it's all
about like what are you doing right now
and tomorrow and we're still really
pumped about the stuff we're doing we
got a lot of really cool ideas with our
existing products to integrate them a
little bit better to make them better
I'm really really really into polishing
things these days we talk about polish a
lot of the business so it's easy in the
software world to keep adding new things
but I really like the idea of taking
what we have and polishing it making it
better and that doesn't mean making it
shiny like blingy but like making it
better and really optimizing and making
things more efficient and I just love
that process as well
so take making something that took you
know two minutes to do before make it
into a minute in ten seconds like it's a
really satisfying thing for me and
there's a lot of room for that so I love
that I just love that small businesses
don't have to use crappy software
anymore so I'd love to be able to build
software for them and not take like a
lot of big companies they take their big
flagship product and like pull a bunch
of out of it and then called small
business software which is an insult to
small businesses so I like to build
stuff for them but they really need so I
love that process and get to meet them
all the time and get to hear about you
know how our products are changing their
lives which is really really rewarding
so I love that and I love the thing I'm
really into right now is seeing my team
grow not like grow in size but everyone
getting better I love that so I love
like the mentoring and the teaching side
of it that I'm really into these days
I'm doing a little bit less work on the
products themselves personally and more
of mentoring and teaching and that sort
of thing which is really really
rewarding as well so that's kind of the
stuff that's really got me excited and
I'm really pumped about our new book
rework which will be out soon like that
is something I cannot wait to get that
book out because it's it's got a lot of
the ideas we talked about a lot of other
ideas that are I don't think they're
radical but they will be seen as radical
and I love that I love be able to shake
things up not just for the shaking it up
because I think these ideas are
important and people should not take
things so seriously and not make things
so hard on themselves and that's where
things I really want to get that message
out there it's a lot of entrepreneurs
that I mean
are frustrated by how hard everything is
and I'm like what's hard and they tell
me what's hard I'm like you don't have
to do any of that stuff I don't have to
have these board meetings all the time
you know if they have meetings all the
time you don't to write plans all the
time you don't to think that far ahead
all it you don't have to do that stuff
like so I can't wait to get that message
out to I'm really excited about that so
those are the things that kind of keep
me pumped up right now